well welcome everybody to the first of
two frankie visiting fellows lectures uh
our opportunity to share with a larger
yale community
work in progress by james mccauley
tonight and by alejandra oliva on
thursday april 21st
the frankie visiting fellows serve as
catalysts for intellectual gatherings at
the whitney humanities center
setting their own agendas and presenting
their work to the community
their presence ensues ongoing
interdisciplinary exchange and creative
debate at the whitney in particular and
at yale in general
frankie visiting fellows are an integral
part of the whitney humanities center
fellowship and this year i've been
especially grateful to james mccauley
and alejandra oliva for their supportive
presence in our wednesday fellows forum
the frankie visiting fellows program is
made possible by the generosity of
richard and barbara frankie
who have done so much for the whitney
humanities center
tonight i'm delighted to introduce james
mccauley whom we've come to know as jake
he graduated from harvard with a degree
in history and literature
awarded a marshall scholarship in his
senior year he went on to complete a phd
in history at oxford university
then served as paris correspondent for
the washington post while he continued
his research in french history
in
2021 jake published the house of fragile
things jewish art collectors in the fall
of france just now awarded the
national jewish book award it was all
over twitter last night
this gripping book
really gripping book takes us into the
world of the great jewish art collectors
of 20th century france describing their
contribution to a french nation that
ultimately betrayed and destroyed them
next jake will publish a biography of
the zionist philanthropist ed mondojos
chield in yale university press's jewish
lives series
the work jake has been doing here at the
whitney widens his lens
black milk of dawn will be an
overarching history of holocaust memory
reconsidered at this crucial moment when
the last witnesses are dying
he will show that there was never
anything automatic about naming or
remembering the holocaust
and that denial and revisionism
have dogged the efforts of historians
from the beginning
this is a courageous project for he's
willing to look at the cracks in the
edifice of holocaust memory and to
interrogate its possible futures
i should add that jake is one of my
favorite opinion writers
whether he's writing about the demise of
the french left in the new york review
of books
calling putin on his distortions in the
washington post or challenging alan
finkelcrout on cancel culture hysteria
on false couture radio
jake's exemplary engagement as historian
and critic shows that understanding the
past can contribute to being a positive
agent for change in one's own time
please join me in welcoming jake
mccauley
uh
um well thank you so much alice for that
very kind introduction and indeed for
having me here at the whitney it has
been just an incredible opportunity to
read and think and
reflect these past couple of months and
i'm afraid you're going to have to prime
me out of the office when the clock runs
out
and thank you
to all of our audience members for
joining tonight
i really appreciate that
and it has been just a pleasure more
than i can say
to be here and to begin the research for
my next book
which alice mentioned briefly and which
is tentatively titled black milk of dawn
jewish survival and holocaust memory
i'm going to talk with you today about
salo barone one of the principal
characters in that story a man whose
personal journey i find immensely
inspiring and whose historical writings
i find compelling confusing
and from time to time frustrating sort
of all at once
and i should say that um you know i had
my background in french history and
these are sort of new readings for me
and i'm well aware that many of our
esteemed uh guests in the audience
tonight are are far more well-versed
than i am in barone and all of his work
so
um please let me know if i get anything
wrong and i welcome any um any feedback
you may have um at the end
um but first of all a brief bit of
biography on barone um whose student
yosef yerushalmi later called him the
greatest uh sorry
this is this is baron himself whose
student um joseph your shomey later
called him the greatest jewish historian
of the 20th century a title i don't
think anyone has ever disputed and that
i myself will certainly not be disputing
tonight
indeed baron who spent his entire career
laboring over his 18-volume social and
religious history of the jews was the
20th century's answer to the likes of
simon dubnav and heinrich greats from
the 19th century like dubnav's
veltgeschtikta and gretz's geshtikta der
yuden barone's social and religious
history
was an attempt by one man to write the
entire course of jewish history a
monumental task if ever there were one
and this was truly his life's work he
began the project as a young scholar and
was constantly expanding the volume
until just before his death in 1989
um and these of of course are baron's
antecedents greats and and dupe now um
so
to continue um baron was born into a
wealthy family in tarnov in galicia
which is in present-day poland his
father was a banker and was also the
president of the town's jewish community
and it was a population of roughly 16
000 according to available estimates
that we have
by all accounts the young baron was
already a polymath in keeping with the
style of local jewish elites at the time
he could speak polish yiddish biblical
and modern hebrew french and german and
his students among whom rank some of the
greatest jewish historians of the 20th
century yerushalmi who whom i've already
mentioned but also arthur hertzberg the
list goes on and on
would recall his ability to lecture
without notes in at least five languages
and here i am lecturing with notes in my
own native language so i mean it's quite
impressive in any case um baron received
rabbinical ordination at the jewish
theological seminary in vienna in the
early 1920s and earned no fewer than
three doctorates from the university of
vienna all by 1923.
he began his teaching career at the
jewish teachers college in vienna
but rabbi stephen wise persuaded him to
move to new york to teach at the jewish
institute of religion there which he did
by the end of the decade and of course
it was there
in new york that he was poached by
columbia university a few short years
later where he became the first to teach
jewish history as a historical
discipline in the american university
and there's been much written about that
including a recent volume by many
leading scholars in the field
celebrating his contribution to jewish
studies in the american university
specifically but just a little bit more
about his attachment to colombia um in
may 1928 linda miller of new rochelle
new york sent a letter to nicholas
butler who was then the president of
colombia informing him of her desire to
establish an endowed chair in jewish
history in honor of her late husband who
had died about six months before
and by the way this is a picture from
the columbia archives of the university
in the 20s sort of around the time when
he would have arrived
and all the letters between linda miller
and butler are in the columbia archives
and miller's vision for this new
teaching role is quite revealing i think
and i quote i should like to make it
clear that it is the spiritual and
intellectual aspects of jewish life that
i should hope to see accentuated in the
courses rather than the nationalistic
ideas which have recently become popular
in some quarters she wrote to the
university president
eventually the search landed on barone
although not without its share of drama
as usual and he took up his post in 1930
and he was on the upper west side until
his retirement until his retirement in
1963.
by the time he arrived at columbia of
course baron was already well known for
an article that is still an essential
reference for all students of jewish
studies and which sadly seems to be the
only piece of his work that is still
widely read today
this
as many of you may guess is the essay
entitled ghetto in emancipation his
famous 1928 argument against the
so-called lacrimos conception of jewish
history before emancipation in the
french revolution this was a hugely
influential intervention and it's this
argument that would inform the rest of
his long and prolific career
and i quote surely barone wrote in the
last line of that piece it is time to
break with the lacrimos theory of
pre-revolutionary woe and to adopt a
view more in accord with historical
truth
i should also note that in that volume i
mentioned um
recently published in honor of barone's
legacy there's a masterful examination
of that essay and its themes by none
other than yale's own david sorkin
but in general baron was skeptical of
the view that saw emancipation as the
solution
to the jewish problem in europe and he
argued contra greats and others that and
i quote there was no complete contrast
between the black of the middle ages and
the white of the post-emancipation
period what mattered for barone was that
jewish history was not to be understood
as a teleology of tragedy or as a saga
of suffering
but baron could scarcely have imagined
or anticipated the brutal century into
which he was born one that was certainly
the most lacrimos of any in the entire
jewish experience
and this is um by the way a photograph
of
barone's hometown tarnov from the u.s
holocaust memorial with um
the
it captures sort of nazi persecutions of
the actual community that he came from
so although he had left europe years
before the holocaust was more than a
rupture in his understanding of jewish
history and its evolution it was a
deeply personal rupture as well and this
i think is a significantly
under-appreciated aspect of his own
story and scholarship most of his family
that had remained in europe including
his parents and his sister were murdered
but even still
he continued with his argument against
the lachrymose theory insisting that
jewish history could not be allowed to
become a history of persecution alone
but that it was a history of the
intellectual cultural and even spiritual
responses that the jews had faced as a
people throughout their long history
baron found solace in the promise and
the reality of jewish survival at least
as he understood it in my readings so
far
and there are so many of them when it
comes to stella barone among the most
poignant has been the conclusion of
volume 3 of barone's first draft of a
social and religious history of the jews
which was published by columbia
university press in 1937
so after hitler's rise to power after
the nuremberg laws but before the full
extent of nazi barbarity was clear
at the end of this shorter although
still three volume version of the book
that would later become barone's magnum
opus
he acknowledges the concern he correctly
assumed would be on his reader's minds
would the jewish people withstand the
nazi menace gaining traction by the day
he was adamant in his response and he
insisted that the answer was already
clear in the course of the history he
had told in the approximately thousand
pages up to that point
and here i quote the answer to the
searching question of our time is
evidently given he wrote the jewish
people and their religion are going to
survive the present extraordinary crisis
and he
underscored our going
he quoted the book of isaiah and called
on jewish leaders to quote seeing a new
sing unto the lord a new song a song
that rebuilt jewish life throughout
through culture and education as a value
worthy of affirmation
but this was before the final solution a
catastrophe that would touch baron
personally and professionally because
the man who argued so powerfully that
jewish history itself was a form of
solace and a blueprint for regeneration
in and of itself was suddenly confronted
with the question of memory specifically
what to remember about the holocaust
which in barone's time did not yet even
have a name
how much weight was this unspeakable
event which baron initially called the
great catastrophe to be given in the
long deray of jewish history the likes
of which he wrote over the course of his
entire career
and most importantly did it represent
the refutation of the anti-lacrimos
convictions once and for all
in my talk today i'm going to examine
baron not so much as a historian but as
an historical actor himself
as someone involved intimately with the
construction of holocaust memory in two
key moments first in offenbach after the
war with the jewish cultural
reconstruction project
and then at the eichmann trial where he
was a star witness for the prosecution
in zachor the classic 1982 treatise on
jewish history versus jewish memory
written by barone's student yerushalmi
we are asked the following question in
the introduction
and here i quote yorushalmi but what
were the jews to remember and by what
means
barone himself had his answers and his
life and his career were a sort of
explanation
so to begin with offenbach after the war
um before the end of the second world
war the american jewish conference
published a pamphlet entitled program
for post-war jewish reconstruction
calling for an end to anti-semitism aid
for surviving european jews a war a war
crimes tribunal and restitution of
stolen property it was baron who wrote
this pamphlet and it was significant
that he used the word reconstruction
this was very much the view of american
jewish organizations in those days
unable to process
um in the sort of minute detail the
unfolding disaster in its full totality
and therefore focusing on the um on what
was to come after the war which had yet
to arrive
baron was seemingly incapable at that
time of grasping the extent of the
ongoing persecutions in europe not to
mention their intensification like many
other jewish scholars of his time
especially in the united states he
assumed that the jews would survive
nazism as they had survived other
pogroms and expulsions in the past in
1940 baron wrote the following
reflecting on the nature of europe's
multinational empires that he so valued
it has been an old historic and this is
i'm qui this is and i quote it has been
an old historic experience that the jews
suffered more heavily in purely national
states than in countries of multiple
nationality germany's nationalistic
spirit draws the country irresistibly
into military adventures should it win
and conquer large territories it would
lose its national homogeneity and become
a state of multiple nationality which
incidentally might cool its anti-semitic
zest
so that's baron in 1940.
eventually baron and others confronted
with the
were confronted with the extent of the
destruction and the devastation
including the loss of his two parents
and one of his sisters he would later
recall that tarnov which had about 20
000 jews before the war had only about
20 when he next visited in the 1950s
and yet despite his immense personal
trauma and profound loss he refused to
alter his view of either the jewish past
and certainly not the jewish present he
threw himself into aiding survivors
however he could but as an architect of
post-war memory his view seems to have
been or one of the architects i should
say of post-war memory his view seems to
have been that what was most important
to remember was the richness of the
civilization that once was not so much
the evil mechanics of the destruction
itself
baron soon headed what was called the
jewish cultural reconstruction
which was a task force sponsored by the
us government in april 1947 to collect
and distribute airless jewish property
in the american occupied zone of germany
after world war ii so based in offenbach
those who worked with boron in that
project were fellow future arbiters of
holocaust memory not all of whom agreed
with him i should i should note hannah
arendt especially but also lucy
davidovich and gershom shalom were all
in some ways involved with this post-war
restitution project so this um the
the the archives in washington dc have
many of the materials pertaining to this
task force this is one of them um here
is hannah arendt one of barone's
sort of his deputy and colleagues in
that
that major undertaking and here is lucy
davidovich as a young
as a young student um
let's see
um
through jewish cultural reconstruction
baron was building a holocaust memory
that was based on his image of the
jewish people's enduring strength and
above all else will to survive he by no
means ignored the extent of the
catastrophe in europe a catastrophe that
as we've mentioned had claimed members
of his own family but he was
nevertheless invested in designing and
advocating
a means of continuation by whatever
means
and here i turn to the historian barbara
kirschenblatt gimblet who has written
that baron insisted that there were two
essential elements in what she calls
jewish continuity that is first a
maintained commitment to tradition
and second the enduring ties of jewish
community so in 1945 before the war had
even ended
baron was still expressing these hopes
um however fanciful they may seem to us
now and here i quote religious history
has given us evidence of how deeply
humanity may sink and still rise again
to high spiritual levels it is not
unreasonable to hope that out of the
depths of misery and despair some new
saving forms of belief and observance
may arise which will provide an answer
to the perplexities of our jewish
experience
as the historian elizabeth goloss has
noted in her brilliant recent study a
mortuary of books barone's general idea
was that salvaging the material remains
of jewish civil of the jewish
civilization that had been
would keep future generations building
on those traditions of the past and
furthering jewish knowledge in the
present as galas writes
his efforts to salvage cultural property
fit with the notion in every respect
symbolizing the potential to secure and
preserve past worlds their knowledge and
traditions
when he was asked to sum up the work of
the jcr the
this organization in 1955
baron underscored all of those themes
and he wrote the jewish people succeeded
in salvaging 500 000 volumes 1200
scrolls of law seven thousand artistic
and ceremonial objects he wrote far
beyond their monetary value these
collections symbolize the continuity of
the heritage of the jewish people in a
letter he sent to the state department
the objects he and his team were able to
recover especially the books were the
material manifestations of the legacy he
sought to reconstruct
he wrote that books have always been the
very lifeblood of the people of the book
which shows that for him books were a
kind of representation of the jewish
people as a whole
to save their orphaned books was thus to
preserve what mattered most about the
jews as a civilization and a culture
and this um as you can see this is a
photo of um some of the books that were
recovered in that sort of offenbach
initiative
and
now to look at the eichmann trial a
little bit and baron's testimony at that
moment so the next moment when he was a
major actor in the emergence of
holocaust memory was the eichmann trial
which needs no introduction
it's unclear if baron ever knew he
wasn't the israeli government's first
choice as the prosecution's star witness
they had wanted the historian and jurist
jacob robinson who served as a special
adviser on jewish affairs at the
nuremberg trials to israel
and also to israel at the united nations
most famously robinson would write the
blistering rebuttal to hana arentz
eichmann and jerusalem
a book entitled and the crooked shall be
made straight but the israeli consulate
in new york reached barone on the upper
west side regardless inviting him to
participate in what was certainly among
the most important events in the
post-war attempt to establish a durable
memory of the holocaust
the significance of the eichmann trial
in the history of holocaust memory is
impossible to understate the dramatic
arrest and extradition of adolf eichmann
from argentina sedated and dressed in an
ll flight attendant's uniform
now captured in various popular films
and novels that i'm sure many of us have
seen was not just an attempt by the
young state of israel to establish
itself on the world stage although it
was certainly a watershed moment in the
country's history in the words of the
historian tom segev once ben gurion
solemnly announced that the government
had eichmann in custody and i quote
israelis had not known since the
declaration of independence so deep a
sense of national unity but the trial
was more than a mere illustration of
national strength it was a deliberate
attempt to show the world just what had
befallen the jewish people as a whole
little more than a decade before
and here i quote the famous first
paragraph of the chief prosecutor gideon
hausner who is
on the left right there
he gave a 10-hour speech at the trial
and this is this is the the first
paragraph of his um kind of quite
amazing speech
um when i stand before you hear judges
of israel to lead the prosecution of
adolf eichmann i am not standing alone
with me are six million accusers but
they cannot rise to their feet and point
an accusing finger towards him who sits
in the dock and cry i accuse for their
ashes are piled up high on the hills of
auschwitz and the fields of treblinka
and are strewn in the forest of poland
their graves are scattered throughout
the length and breadth of europe their
blood cries out but their voice is not
heard therefore i will be their
spokesman and in their name i will
unfold the terrible indictment
visibility was paramount to that
indictment journalists from around the
world covered the trial as we all know
hannah arendt but also elie wiesel and
hugh trevor roper from britain among
others
most importantly as many of you know
this was the first trial ever to be
recorded for television as only select
portions of the post-war nuremberg
trials were filmed but a television
network recorded the daily proceedings
which were then flown out every night to
the europe and the u.s quite the
undertaking for 1961.
but this was the point of the entire
exercise as gideon hausner would later
recall
the idea was that the whole world could
watch
baron took his assignment of being the
historical consciousness of these six
million
absent accusers
extremely seriously his student the
great historian and rabbi arthur
hertzberg later recalled that he had
never seen his professor as anxious as
he was during his final preparations for
the trial
and the israeli government had made his
assignment clear in order to convict
eichmann forcefully in order to
demonstrate the full extent of his
brutality and his evil the prosecution
needed to show the significance of what
the nazis had done and just what exactly
they had destroyed
in advance of the trial housener and
this i borrowed from deborah lipstot's
book on the trial hausner had written to
barone that it was important to prove
the nazi intention to annihilate the
jewish people and it is therefore vital
for the trial to present documentation
that will expose the national and
cultural value of the jewish centers
that were destroyed in the
holocaust when barone arrived in israel
in late march 1961 he had an audience
with none other than ben gurion himself
and of course that is ben gurion
um
we don't know exactly how the
conversation went but we do have what
ben gurion wrote in his diary after the
encounter which was that and i quote it
is important to make clear to our youth
the magnitude of the qualitative loss
resulting from the extermination of six
million and therefore describe the
spiritual character of the jewry that
was exterminated present outstanding
personalities like einstein bialik
dubnov etc and the historian um deborah
lipschat whom i just mentioned has
written in that same book that ben
gurion and hausner were deeply anxious
that barone a professor
would come across as boring and hausner
actually tried to tell the renowned
scholar from columbia university to make
sure his remarks were engaging which did
not go over well
boredom
as barone said boredom is relative and
very often depends on the manner in
which the facts are presented he snapped
back anyway nothing was more boring than
the testimony of the yad vashem
representative regarding the validity of
certificates and documents and yet you
accepted this testimony as being
essential to the trial hausner let it go
you will of course express your opinions
on historical issues as you see fit he
assured the visiting professor
your unique scientific standing and your
publications are significant or
sufficient guarantee that the picture
you present will be accurate and
enthralling
when baron finally entered the witness
box about two weeks into the trial the
judge asked him to put on the kippah and
to take the oath he obliged but then
quickly took off the kippah apologizing
for his imperfect hebrew and delivering
what was in many ways one of the most
important speeches he ever gave
baron's testimony was lengthy but
certain parts of it show how he tried to
preserve his anti-lacrimal conception by
presenting the nazi menace as something
that was entirely separate and distinct
from previous pogroms or anti-jewish
persecutions
and this is barone in the witness
box
the attempt to see auschwitz as the
culmination of the long history of
anti-semitism he suggested
entirely missed the point
and i quote such assertions maligned the
middle ages he said while on the stand
although there has been immemorial
anti-semitism it is well to remember
that there was practically no violence
accompanied by bloodshed under the
persians or the greeks there were minor
outbreaks in the days of philo of
alexandria there were no pogroms under
the muslims
but in keeping with both his earlier
scholarship and his work in offenbach
salvaging the remnants of jewish culture
baron also used his testimony to offer
most of all an impassioned defense of
the diaspora and all that it had
achieved
and here i quote
a passage from from his from his own
remarks as a permanent minority for some
2000 years jews were forced to seek the
kinds of openings that were available to
newcomers when they found and used such
opportunities they were working for both
their own benefit and that of society as
a whole i have long believed that much
of jewish history ought to be rewritten
in terms of the pioneering services
which the jews were forced to render by
the particular circumstances of their
history and he continued with courage
and perseverance the jewish people tried
to adjust the new situation not merely
passively but independently and
creatively accustomed to the long
history of their dispersion to such
creative adjustments they were able to
develop during the interwar period
certain new forms of communal and
cultural living which fructified jewish
life throughout the world contributed
significantly to human civilization and
held out great promise for the future
all this was cut short by the nazi
attack unprecedented in scope geographic
extension and murderous intensity and in
another moment in his remarks he said
the following
of course the jewish people also had its
sinners and idiots thieves and lunatics
but on balance future historians are
likely to call the first third of the
20th century the golden age of ashkenazi
jewry in europe just as they will see in
it the beginning of a modern sephardi
renaissance
the israelis were upset with this
testimony again we have mostly just ben
gurion's diary which was unsparing in
its criticism of barone just as i feared
ben gurion wrote we had failed miserably
adding that baron embarrassed us deeply
the precise reasons for that opinion are
unclear but the historian hana yablanca
has suggested that it was likely that
baron had merely contradicted what was
becoming the official israeli narrative
about the holocaust namely that it had
marked the end of european jewish
civilization which had been doomed for
centuries anyway
but barone's convictions could not be
shaken
in conclusion i think it's worth
revisiting baron's conception of jewish
survival as he aged so in 1963 the year
of his retirement from colombia he
published an essay entitled newer
emphases in jewish history which was a
revision of an earlier essay he had
written on the same topic years before
and this is a text in which he revisited
his criticism of the lacrimos conception
of jewish history
all my life he wrote i have been
struggling against the hitherto dominant
lacrimos conception of jewish history a
term which i have been using for more
than 40 years because i have felt that
an overemphasis on jewish sufferings
distorted the total picture of the
jewish historic evolution and at the
same time
badly served a generation which had
become impatient with the nightmare of
endless persecutions and massacres
that line is often cited but what
follows is not which is baron actively
grappling with the extent of the
holocaust devastation insisting that and
i quote we must not misunderstand the
true realities of life and psychology
among those who had endured the recent
catastrophe including the inherent
tragedies of jewish life during the two
millennia of the dispersion
this i think points to an important
dimension of his opposition to the
lacrimos theory as he aged
it
it comes across as though he doesn't
have a firm answer anymore and that
perhaps the lack the his the
anti-lacrimal critique was never meant
as an explanation for everything that
could be applied at will
as we've seen it was an active choice
that was neither self-evident nor
inevitable and one with whom many others
certainly disagreed although today it
has gained quite a dominant position
but
perhaps most of all for someone who had
lost so much
this way of writing and thinking the
jewish past was itself a form of
survival not collective survival but
personal survival
and that is the conclusion of my talk
[Applause]
yes with pleasure
thank you very much thank you that was
very moving
can you say something about his wife uh
gene i
i believe
jeannette yeah
my recollection is that she was a sort
of a full-time secretary and uh
research assistant but you know never
appeared
on the title page of any any of his work
absolutely i mean i believe um you know
his wife was absolutely influential on
his work and you know more than just as
a secretary as a real collaborator and
in many ways
um a social history a social and
religious history of the jews is work
that they did together
and you're right that she does not
appear on the title page of the books
but it it's um from everything we know
about how the book was produced and how
it was written especially as it was
revised in later editions she was hugely
hugely influential on how it was put
together
thank you for that jake could you say
something about what
motivated you to take on this project
ah well um
how much time do we have um
you know i think i
i i guess i've
been interested in these questions for a
very long time
particularly as
an american jew who grew up
i was born in 1989 sort of right before
the fall of the berlin wall in which you
know at no point in my
education
was the holocaust not a
kind of major cornerstone so you know
that had a history that had a whole sort
of literature behind it and i just
became very interested as indeed so many
others have and how
we arrived at this conception that we
know so much about today which is the
holocaust which you know might have
assumed and did assume different forms
in different cultural contexts and so
looking at the immediate post-war
with
these characters with these sort of
active debates raging in that time was
very interesting to me to see
sort of the choices that were made and
how we came to remember what we came to
remember and what like how they emerge
as they did but also what might have
been um because there were
as we all know
many other paths this whole memory
project could have taken and so i find
it quite interesting how it did evolve
as it has
thank you
that was a wonderful talk i'm really
compelled by your
approach of thinking of him as a
historical actor and not just a
historian and i would just love to hear
you speak more about that how that
methodology came up for you
um because i just find it really
compelling yeah well thank you so much
for that question i'm not i'm not sure
it's um
it's
uh
super
uh complicated or anything i mean it
just it struck me that
in the aftermath of the war you have not
just barone but so many others um like
hannah arendt lucy davidovich um the
list goes on
these
were all the first and like raul
hillberg um
etc these were all you know the first
major historians of the holocaust i mean
barone not so much the historian of the
holocaust but you know major jewish
historians of the time grappling with
the holocaust i should say
and
you know
they they
they were these amazing and baroness
case just stupendously prolific
scholars but
they were more than that i mean they
were they were active participants in i
mean many of them like barone you know
had had um the experience of having
family killed you know aren herself was
a refugee
davidovich had been in vilna before the
war and had come back to europe to do
this part so they were not just sort of
passive observers of the events the
events had shaped all of their lives
intimately
and i just think it's a mistake not to
consider both at the same time and to
consider the scholarship in some senses
as an expression of
the
personal journeys that so many of them
had because in a way
that
was the sort of emotional
drive behind so much of it or so it
seems to me
thank you jake that was a
elegant analysis of cello baron
in in in terms of the impact of the
holocaust on baron
i think that
the whole question of legal status and
guarantee of rights it was central for
him
after all baron was stateless
for over 10 years
it was only when wise
invited him to come to new york to the
jewish institute of religion that wise
was able to um
flex his muscles with the state
department
and to get barona visa and u.s
citizenship
um
but you know in his in his later in his
essays from the 1960s
um which i think reflected his own
experience of statelessness with the
collapse of the
austro-hungarian monarchy
he wrote about the insufficiency of the
of this nation state
as guaranteeing the rights of jews and
other minorities
and looked forward to there being some
kind of organization of course the
united nations existed the league of
nations had failed at that but
some kind of international organization
which would guaran which would guarantee
basic rights
so you know i'm wondering if you could
just comment yeah i mean i think um
that's certainly i mean again you know
this way way better than i do so i mean
that that's absolutely something i will
think more about as i continue my
research but that in terms of what
at least i have thought about so far um
i mean i think you absolutely get that
sense in what he wrote about nazism sort
of even at the time i even quote one of
the passages where he says that it is
this sort of national character of the
enterprise that's so hostile to the jews
and in fact if nazi germany had become
this sort of
empire of sorts that was multinational
multilingual etc then perhaps things
might have been otherwise so i think i
think you're absolutely right um i mean
as for what he imagined in the long term
and the post-war i don't know as much um
but
i i don't know i i think um
i think the
the emphasis on these kind of
supernational organizations would would
put him in the context of many other
thinkers of his times i mean it's not
necessarily unique in that regard
but that's a really good
point to examine further
thank you this has been enjoyable and
moving and i want to ask you whether
there's it felt like there was an
intimation of a
kind of anti-jewish nationalist
trajectory first from the letters
creating barone's uh post and then uh in
kind of his conflict explicit our
implicit with ben gurion at the trial
and i'm sorry you've made kind of no
reference to
how the creationist state of israel did
or didn't shape uh baron's picture and
not ask you to speak to kind of the
present but in terms of thinking about
is this emphasis on a spiritual
status which he's how he referred to
european jewry a kind of a consistent
through line that pla did in fact place
him at odds with a more political or
nationalist orientation towards
jewishness so that is an excellent
question and i'm very glad you raised
that um
i think if i had more time i would have
sort of delved into that aspect of his
work so but first of all you know barone
was a zionist absolutely
i think the
perceived conflict which i'm not sure
was an actual conflict with ben gurion
at the end
was
perhaps over what kind of zionism each
imagined so i don't think that barone
was in any way anything but supportive
of the establishment i mean he had
visited several times before eichmann i
mean it wasn't something that he
opposed by any means and and he was a
sort of um outspoken supporter of it i
just think that
um
he did not necessarily
agree with the
i guess official narrative at the time
which was to sort of disparage the
diaspora as worthless as doomed to fail
as
um something that was
nothing but the anti-chamber to
auschwitz and i think that that was the
uh disagreement if ever there were one i
mean but yeah he was absolutely a
zionist for sure
yeah of course
you allude to him and i think his
follows up on the previous uh
question and that is there seems to be a
narrative that could be spelled out in
terms of his relation to sholum
two i mean towering yes intellectuals
academics but of very different sorts
and and of course
was also involved in reclamation of
books from uh after the holocaust so
there's in some ways
there are unparalleled paths which
absolutely don't intersect or don't or
maybe intersect more than we've been
able to see
i mean i think one of the things that's
been so interesting for me about this
whole project is just
the
sort of interpersonal relationships
among as you say so many of these
towering figures that we all know such
as sholem baron but also hana arent
i mean i was i was fascinated to learn
that i mean
i think barone
shared in the criticism of eichmann in
jerusalem but ultimately
um was very close with rn i mean in fact
i i believe it was the barons who were
in hanaren's apartment when she died and
who called the ambulance to collect her
i mean so there was this sort of
intimacy among this whole generation
that went through these events together
even if they
they disagreed so one of the things i'm
hoping to do in the book is to tease out
as much as possible some of those
personal relationships that stitch these
characters together because i think
that's quite
um
it's quite illuminating and it shows the
the way that the dis well i mean as we
all know from people who live in the
real world that disagreements between
brilliant people are not always
intellectual in nature that there were
sort of petty
personal
elements of it as well and i think that
that's equally important in
understanding how these
these ideas and how these arguments get
mobilized and defended so i absolutely
agree
jake this was just really um
so fascinating and obviously is just in
par
a part of what you're going to be
creating in this next book can you give
us a preview of i mean you have just
started to give us a preview of the
other aspects that you're going to bring
the other people in the other aspects
can you fill that out even more
obviously this is sure early on yeah
well it's curious it's sort of uh um
it's sort of being planned as we speak
but basically um
i
i have several characters one of which
is barone but also um
uh hannah arendt lucy davidovich
raul hillberg and ellie wiesel for the
moment and looking at the i mean um
that's it's i should say as we all know
it is an enormous huge amount of
material but the way that i'm trying to
sort of find my way through is to follow
the characters at moments when they all
reappear and again as i mentioned they
all knew each other and were largely in
contact in many cases for their entire
lives so one of those moments would be
offenbach when so many of the characters
work together another is the eichmann
trial when a lot of them have cameo
appearances in different ways
um and then again in new york in the
1970s when so many are kind of debating
um like lucy davidovich and hillberg for
instance
the
the meaning of it all and so that's um
that's how i've structured it and
i
i hope that it will that it will come
together but we shall we shall see
really i had a very similar question
yeah but an angle on the question which
you know you're talking about the
construction of a memory so i wonder
when does it begin for you and i guess
that's a question of imagination when
does what begin the memory of the
holocaust when does it begin or when
does the story you're telling begin yeah
um
that is another excellent question um
i think
the memo
the question of when it begins has to be
before the war is even over
um
absolutely and i think that um
you know there are several important
examples but you know one of them would
be
um
with the story of emmanuel wrinklebloom
and the warsaw ghetto sort of actively
collecting
traces of the destruction while it was
happening and shoving them underground
to make sure that someone someday
somehow would find them and know
now that's not necessarily
telling people what the memory should be
and arbitrating the shape and contours
of it but it is providing raw sort of
primary sources if you will
for
someone else to construct it but it does
show a consciousness of the world
historical significance of the event
while it was unfolding and the
imperative to have some basis to
remember it so i would say it definitely
begins
um
after the i mean while the war is still
is still raging
um
but then also i think
some of the
most important post-war
beginnings of the the memory question
were the question of names right
um and i mentioned that you know at the
very beginning like for scholars like
barone what barone initially called the
great catastrophe had no official name
you know many used different names to
describe it and what's fascinating to
observe and to and to look at is
the evolution of each of the terms
offered to describe what we now call the
holocaust in english but which is called
the shoah in hebrew and french
how
the terms
emerged what their antecedents were what
kind of implications
they
they gave the event and how it shaped
public understandings of them so i think
that that's probably the next really
crucial step
all right
well thank you all for coming so much
[Applause]